so Boehner went from 30 to 650 people in
four years and from one to five offices
including London and you know the way
I've kept culture is dictatorship
you know it's just the thing that I care
about the most and so you know here's
how you keep culture when Kristen in the
office is upset about something and I'm
on my way from Connecticut into New York
to do a new business pitch potentially
worth five million dollars and I detour
and skip that pitch to go and talk out
with her that issue that's how you
maintain culture guys life's very simple
there's there's the things you wish you
were doing there's the things you're
saying that you're doing and then
there's the things that you actually do
the way you maintain culture is the same
answer as the question prior to this you
do it
in your actions I don't meet with every
single employee that works for me for
ten minutes three months in to check the
box and seem like a personal CEO I do it
because in those 10 minutes I want to
create some sort of connection that
makes them feel comfortable to say hi to
me in the elevator or to like come with
a problem to me I do it because I asked
them where their hometown is so I can
make a joke about the Cleveland Indians
in the elevator to show them that I was
paying attention I do it because I want
to know if they are have siblings how
they roll what interests are they in
because if I want to surprise and
delight them because they're crushing it
that I can get them coachella tickets
right I do it because it has purpose and
so I maintain culture very simply
dictatorship my actions and the number
one and two other options are
meritocracy letting talent speak for
itself and then finally firing the most
talented people if they're not willing
to care about their teammates more than
them thinking they're fancy and you know
my ego is so big that I don't think I
need anybody that works for my company
and so thus they're all expendable if
they're not willing to treat each other
with respect and love